[Musique]
imaginez un tout petit peut être dans un
pays qui n'est pas un autre et en plus
ne maîtrisez pas avant et pire vous avez
avoir des problèmes financiers
c'était ma situation quant au stade
jusqu'à sualg aux états unis la vie
était belle
je recevais de l'argent près par an et
un jour s'était coupé c'est la fin de la
faim comme l avait dit donc il va
falloir que je fasse un audit persona de
ma vie pour être conscient ce que j'ai
remarqué j'avais trois problèmes premier
manque d'éducation financière
waziers du deuxième à des confidences et
le p suivant je comprenais pas la langue
mais j'ai compris finalement que je
devais attaquer un point qui est très
important c'est l'éducation financière
parce que sans ça je pouvais pas réussi
aux états unis donc du coup j'ai
commencé à me documenter
je commençais à votre question gens à
savoir plus comment gérer
comment économiser convaincu de la carte
de crédit est simpliste et
l'investissement et aux autres et à peu
près je commencer par avoir des
connaissances dans tous ces domaines et
je me suis dit je ne pouvais pas le
quinqua garder tous ses connaissances
mais j'aurais partager avec les autres
car j'ai aussi appris que la meilleure
façon de s'enrichir c'est de partager et
ce que nous ne faisons pas la plupart
nous gardons tous avec nous la même
façon de s'enrichir c'est de partager
avec les gens des connaissances scandale
là tout le monde venait sûrement pour
des questions sur la gérance le buzet tu
seras et je me suis dit mais bon il faut
que j'écrive un livre à ce sujet mais
premier que coma écrit un livre en
anglais tu ta langue le français est là
tout le monde commence à se moquer de
moi
marcourt n'ose pas possible tu perds
qu'un livre qui va le lire on est
africaine on ne le fait pas on est ici
pour étudier pour repartir en afrique
j'apparais tous et toutes cette victoire
mais j'avais la volonté de le faire
parce que j'avais le pourquoi tu avais
le pourquoi mais tout le temps mais elle
me disait non ne le fait pas c'est pas
possible
comment est ce que tu vas le faire aux
fins de mon corps aussi je ne savais pas
le comprends mais je savais pourquoi
injuste appartiennent conférence
j'ai rencontré l'auteur qui écrit un
livre intitulé vivez votre vie sans
regret vivez votre vie sans regret là je
prends le livre je regarde le livre mais
je me regarde je savais pas qu'ils
étaient vraiment conçu avec le livre il
marcha vers moi et me dit jeune homme
vous appréciez mali monsieur monsieur
j'aime beaucoup votre livre un jour je
vois devenu auteur écrivain qu'on vaut
il me regarda me disais pourquoi un jour
j'ai dit monsieur je suis africain je
suis noir je ne comprends pas bien
l'anglais
je peux pas tu donnes tout sa raison il
me regarde avec un oeil inquiet et me
dit ce jeune homme nous a beaucoup de
talent vous a beaucoup d'opportunités
j'ai confiance à vous vous avez écrit ce
livre qui dit non monsieur vous ne
comprenez pas je suis pas dit si je peux
pas me dit vous pouvez on se regarde on
prend une minute
j'étais vraiment confus je ne sais pas
quoi dire
tu me rappelle très bien mon retour
quant à quitter phoenix ou omaha
nebraska où je vivais on a fait une
escale chicago mais dans l'avion
il avait le bois qui me dit marco tu
peux le faire une fois qu'ils me
disaient non tu veux pas le faire qu'ils
étaient 1 7 2 voilà qui me disent ne
faire le le droit dit non tu peux pas le
faire
arrivée à chicago je me suis assis dans
l'avion entre en quelques mois et
j'avais ce livre dans ma main comme ça
comme un bébé
je regardais en croit les mêmes ceux qui
étaient assis à côté de moi il me
demandait qu'à ça c'est qu'un livre ça
et naucelle monsieur que j'ai rencontré
les auteurs et je disais monsieur un
jour je vais écrire un livre aussi les
médias bomb et deux sud africains et me
dit ok je pense que tu peux le faire et
ce monsieur là me disait me racontait
l'histoire d'une autre femme qui a eu
tout livre intitulé il s'appelle offerte
en anglais kent is not enough
mehdi mais ça c'est pas du razr dollar
je suis partir j'ai commencé un crémant
premier livre est d'ici j'ai trois
livres actuellement dans le premier
livre c'est une éducation financière
le deuxième lycée sur la diète
estudiantine aux états unis le troisième
ou sociaux le serbe leadership parce que
j'ai compris que tous ici nous sommes
des leaders que vous acceptez opale à ce
que nous donc des autres à des gens nous
voulons que les gens pensent à des
sommets des fois vous oublions nous
oublions de comment se conduire
la zéro marqué dedans la vie avant que
nous puissions réussir notre récompense
une seule chose qu'on doit curieux on
doit être que deuxièmement la plus
importante
il faut savoir le pourquoi pourquoi
est-ce que vous êtes ici pourquoi est ce
que il est votre ami pourquoi est ce
qu'ils avaient marie on doit savoir
pourquoi quand le pourquoi et fort le
processus de toutes choses évoluent
pendant le pourquoi on arrive à obtenir
ces bus quand le pourquoi dans la
motivation de conquérir
on connaît l'autre pourquoi thonon
pourquoi est vraiment forts ont réussi
c'est pour ça que des pans de bois des
petits enfants vous demandez question
pourquoi ça comble de la réponse ils
posent encore la question pourquoi
en que vous n'avez pas la réponse de
l'autre pourquoi ça vous serait
difficile et des fois chaque matin quand
vous leur posez vous la question
pourquoi je me suis bien sûr il ya des
gens qui meurent chaque seconde est et
si vous êtes en vie
profitez-en pour que vous ne devez pas
votre vie sans regret c'est quelque
chose qui est vraiment mer et douloureux
je suis convaincu que nous tous qui
sommes ici nous avons des talents
nous avons des dons il va falloir qu'on
se réveille contrat va sucer d'or et
qu'on oublie la peur et qu'on oublie que
nos amis me disent que non tu peux pas
réussir
tu peut échouer c'est un problème on
peut seulement apprendre de nos échecs
et de les faire mieux d'une autre façon
au fait les sexes n'est pas nouvelle
chose les fêtes les cercles dont
l'opportunité de se reconstruire
dahan de nouveau mais ce qui est
important c'est que qui sont vos amis
qui vous inspire
et on doit s'inspirer chaque jour si
vous brosser les dents chaque jour vous
dire vous inspirer chaque jour à ce
qu'on vit dans une société qui est
toujours négative on vit dans une
société qui a beaucoup de challenge qui
est de négativité
c'est pour cette raison en construction
motivé cinq jours c'est pour cette
raison qu'on doit avoir des personnes
avec qui ils doivent nous soutenir
sans ça difficile de réussir à marquer
sur coup ce soir est la vôtre pourquoi
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]